breaking news it's giving people a lot  of hope pfizer has announced that there  is a new pill to treat covid which could  save thousands of lives initial results  from a new study show the drug reduced  hospitalizations and deaths by 89  that's right 89 percent in high-risk  adults not only that it can also be used  at home by people exposed to covet or  who have mild symptoms and we also have  more good news from the united kingdom  that country has approved another covert  fighting pill this one from merck  studies there show that the merck pill  reduced hospitalizations and fatalities  by half among recently infected people  the merck pill is set for review in this  country later this month and the pfizer  pill meanwhile still needs to be  submitted for authorization public  health experts do point out that none of  these treatments should be considered a  substitute for getting the vaccine